on today's show we talk about kids and
phobias
and family we talk about being diagnosed
with a terminal illness and what to do
next
and we talked to an incredible 53 year
old woman
who's got a great job and is ready to
change her family tree stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john dolone show i hope
everybody's doing well everybody's
staying dry
staying warm i don't know i guess it's
almost summer now so hopefully you're
do you're not cold how about that and i
hope that um
man the spring's being good to you and
your family it's
beautiful here in nashville and um man
things are starting to wake back up the
trees and the flowers it's good it looks
good looks good things are not good
around the world
but we're going to continue to look for
beauty hey if you want to be on this
show we talk about relationships mental
health
everything anything you can think of
give me a shout at 1-844-693-3290
it's one eight four four six nine three
three two nine one or you can go to www
dot i'm just kidding sorry you can go
johndaloni.com
show fill out the form goes to kelly
she her ratio i don't even know i was
gonna make a kelly joke but she's
staring directly
above that camera and it burned my rods
and cones in my eyes and so i'm gonna
take that jug back
and say kelly's beautiful and smart and
she will take all of your calls so send
them to her
johnny.com show hey and this happened
the other day and this isn't me even
being funny this is like kind of a
serious thing
um so i want to give some some
behind the curtain stuff on just how my
wife and i
make decisions how we live like in the
real world right not just thinking
through stuff so
we're meeting with our my son's teachers
he's going to be moving schools
and
we were having some conversations about
what his um you know what he's going to
be studying next year and what's going
to be learning and
it hit me while we were having this
conversation that we do approach this a
little bit differently
i got a phd in education my wife is a
thousand
and times smarter than me and i'm not
one of those guys that's like no dude
she really is a thousand times smarter a
thousand ex smarter than me
and she's got a phd in education she
actually used to teach teachers we've
both taught
graduate education courses so we've
taught not only teachers but
graduate students and when our
my son's teachers we had all these
different people we're on a zoom call
we're talking to each one of them about
you know his scores and this is an
accent
the questions we kept coming back to for
these folks number one they didn't know
anything about our degrees we'd have any
reason to tell them
there's no flexing that needs to go on
the most important thing for
my son's learning environment is how we
can support
the teachers who are going to be
teaching them not making sure that these
teachers are doing what i think is
that's of no good because then the
teachers have to walk some kind of weird
line between the state curriculum and
the national curriculum and what the
county says they have to do plus their
own training put and my son's gonna
absorb all that disconnect and all that
tension
so the thing that my wife and i kept
asking is hey there are some books that
you all have read
that help
students like mine like our like our son
what are some ways that we can on our
own
gather the language that you're gonna
use in his classroom gather some of the
experiences that you're gonna pass along
to him
so we can do that at home our goal as
parents not as research nerds not as
dorks who went to a lot of college
but our goal as parents is to help
support and reinforce what's going on in
his classroom
so it's a big deal to us to never talk
crap about his teachers
even if we think oh i would not have
done it like that or didn't like this
well then cool then our job is to help
help bridge that gap and that may mean
i've got to
not watch a netflix episode normally it
falls on my wife but
because i'm here at the office but she's
going to not do x y and z she's going to
help reinforce some math stuff
but also we're going to spend some time
reading on our own
to learn the perspective and the lenses
that my son's teachers are using
so that we can use some of that language
so that we can point some of that stuff
out when we're fishing or we're
hiking or hunting hey this is that math
thing she was talking about
so he can begin to get a fuller picture
of what education looks like
so why am i telling you all this two
reasons number one
being a teacher this year has been a
nightmare and we're staring as a
country we are staring down the barrel
of a group of people who are going to
say i'm out
i can just go make this kind of money
doing way different things that are not
so stressful that don't have this many
people yelling at me
that doesn't start at 6 30 in the
morning and end at seven o'clock at
night and then i'm gonna
eat dinner and help with bedtime then
i'm gonna go back to grading papers
whatever so
i want to shift this focus where we've
blamed and yelled and fought and
and kicked and whined about teachers and
educate
i'm gonna stop that we're all gonna stop
that we're not gonna be a part of that
anymore
we're gonna say how can we support these
teachers and that means we're gonna have
to help at home it's gonna be some both
hand
and i think a lot of us learned you know
it's easy to blame
teachers a lot of us had to homeschool
this last year
millions and millions and millions of us
i think we learned
maybe my kid's not an angel or a saint
maybe it wasn't always the fill in the
blank
now schools aren't perfect there's a lot
broken with the system
but most teachers are doing the best
they can and they're real good
or they're really good in in the
circumstances that they are in
so i want to support them number one i'm
going to talk bad about them and then
number two
how can i as a parent bridge that
connective gap
between what my kids learning in the
classroom versus
their life at home so i just wanted to
pass that along here's how we're
actually doing it in our house
we're a bunch of nerds and i'm not going
to pass any of that nerdnam on to my
son's teachers to their son's school
that's not their job their job is to
teach my kid within the system
that they've got my job is to be an
adjunct to that it's to support him to
lift him
and to be a positive voice about his i
want him to love
learning i want him to love making
connections across a bunch of different
platforms so
anyway that's my thought on that let's
get right to the phones we've got some
action-packed calls today i'm assuming
let's go to mark in san diego california
what's up mark how we doing oh
two words john seasonal allergies
brother
i i've got them too man you can hear it
in my voice
man well i hope you're uh i'm here hope
you're rocking it up man
say hey how can i help dude what's up so
january of 2020 um
my mom came to my house and unbeknownst
to us
my younger brother was in tow
turns out how old young was his uh 10
years younger than me so at the time
he was probably 21-ish okay
all right cool um so he
used that opportunity to come out to me
and my family as transgender
okay and that in and of itself
i support him however
that experience traumatized my daughter
and she had just turned six
at the time and so
it was a surprise to us there was no
prep work we didn't have the
opportunity between my wife and i to
talk about if she was old enough mature
enough
to learn about something like that
okay um fast forward about two weeks ago
i i hadn't talked about this with my
sister and i had a conversation with him
and i expressed to him my concerns and
how it traumatized my daughter
she had nightmares for six months about
it
and he laughed it off okay so
she laughed it off my question is really
how do i my daughter's doing better now
but how do i talk to her
really about this now that i'm behind
the eight ball on the subject
yeah and i can't move forward with a
relationship
with my sister until there's some type
of acknowledgement that there was
but the conversation that i want to have
with her is not the fact that
she came out because that's how she took
it
she took it as me attacking the fact
that she's transgender
right yeah when my issue was really look
man you kind of
took a parenting aspect away from my
wife and i
and exposed our daughter to a facet of
society that she was not
mentally ready to handle okay
and her appearance at the time
scared her okay like completely scared
her
so walk me through this trauma because
here's the thing kids are
incredibly malleable because they
don't have all of the pictures that
you and i might have right as 20 30 and
40 year old
and so they can be infinitely more
flexible on
oh okay and they just go about their day
because they don't have these this
you know decades of these other pictures
when you say
trauma with a six-year-old
that to me is somebody screamed at them
or yelled at him or scared him to death
and they had
nightmares my initial thought is
she absorbed y'all's reaction to what
happened and that scared her because she
had never seen mom
and dad and grandma scared to death
unless i'm missing something
i've never heard what you're explaining
i've never heard of this so walk me
through the trauma
correct so my daughter has been
terrified
of people in costumes and masks and face
paint
since as young as we can remember we've
never taken her to disneyland
um she's so scared that at her
school when sparky the fire dog the
firefighter like comes in to greet the
kids because they're gonna do a fire
alarm the teachers know to take her to
another classroom
because she is utterly mortified okay
she has a whole she this is not about
she's got
um a phobia of
a
a person that she knows showed up to her
house
and in her head those phobias converged
right this is somebody i know
now they look differently and they're
acting the same but it looks a little
bit different maybe wearing makeup now
or different clothes
and then so it's less about the
transgender coming out and more about
if he had shown up dressed like a clown
or shown up dressed like a
like chewbacca or something it would
have terrified your dog yes
okay yeah so that's that's that's number
one
what i want to make sure we don't
conflate the two okay
so that did your
sister know this
yes uh she did okay because a year or
two
prior we'd gone to a renaissance fair
it was her idea at the time
yeah and i had to carry my daughter on
my shoulders the whole time
she had her head buried like in the back
of my neck
and i could hear her saying dad i want
to see that person's face can you ask
him to take their mask off
and he ended up leaving early gosh this
cove had been a nightmare for her
i can't even imagine uh i guess maybe
she could see eyes
right yes she can see
eyes and she's also wearing a mask okay
so
it's kind of she's got a place doing it
yeah
okay exactly so yeah i i shouldn't have
led with the transgender
it should have been more the costume and
the mask but it
he he she showed up dressed very goth
okay and all the dark clothes the black
lipstick
and all that it just it scared her sure
so there's there's all of this
to me all this conversation distills
down to a single
word and that's that's hospitality
kindness
right and so when somebody
shows up in a way knowing that
and i want to take transgender off
because it's a third rail right now
showing up with any sort of anything
that is going to
put a child in a position of fear even
if
um uh it's quote unquote
me expressing myself here's a good
example i'll use my house
i've got one of my kids that hates being
touched by strangers until they know
them and then they're
comically over um like they just
they'll be all over them but if somebody
comes in my house and knows that
remembers that from last time
and they immediately grabbed my kid and
won't and their and my kids start
shrieking and yelling and that you know
that how kids tense up
and won't put the kid down yeah dude
that is a
that is a major violation of a child
right
the regulation of a child and so i
forget the transgender stuff i will say
if
your um sibling knew that that's not
cool
and that is the approach for me right
that's the
the conversation you have with any kid
about any issue
anytime anywhere right that's number one
number two when it comes to the
transgender thing it sounds like you're
being incredibly hospitable you're
you are leaning into who your sister
says she is
and you're that's a shift for everyone
in every family
i the approach i take on this is mutual
respect and mutual hospitality
if somebody says hey this is how i'm
going to express myself and this is who
i
am then in my house at the deloney house
in my family and my community
we're going to be super hospitable come
on over let's grab a beer and hang out i
got to hear about this right
and so i don't get caught up in the the
politics of it all
i like talking to human beings at my
kitchen table the other side of that is
if somebody has been known for a long
time
i want them and expect them and need
them to be graceful
during this time right like you have
done on this call
you knew quote unquote brother for 20
something years
and you are doing your best to okay yeah
you asked me to call you this
but i'm gonna stumble over it i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna trip on it
know that my heart's good and i'm
getting there right know that when
you're around my kid i need you to
overly say hey hey and get down on
a knee get down and look at them in the
eye so we can take some of that fear
hierarchy away does that make sense
so basically what i'm telling you is i
want to affirm both sides
of what you're trying to do you're
trying to be a hospitable big brother
and i'm grateful to you for that right
that is gonna communicate a lot to your
kid
about um less again six-year-olds don't
understand the politics
it's it's they don't understand any of
the nonsense going on they're watching
mom and dad how does mom and dad
treat people right and you guys are look
sounds like you're you're
doing great you do have a right to take
again take the transgender stuff off you
do have a right as a parent to say
i can't have you scaring my kid and this
particular thing terrifies my child
i need if you're gonna be around my kid
i need you to be hospitable to my child
and i think his mom and dad this is
gonna be a lifelong thing i'd recommend
um working with a play therapist this
can be this type of
phobia can often be healed if you will
i don't say cured but it can be healed
in relatively short order
it's it doesn't have to go on forever um
you can get a great play therapist that
can walk through some things and gently
connect some dots for your
child and it's pretty remarkable what
they can do
and i'd start there but you were well
within your right to have that
conversation
with your sister about hey
you can quote unquote be you and i don't
care who bu
is but here's how we have to deal with
my kid because my kid has a particular
challenge here right and it's with
people who dress up with masks but
people who
don't look the same as they used to and
now that you
are transitioning and don't look the
same as you used to we got to be
graceful here
and if your sister's a jerk about it
then
they don't have to have access to your
child does that make sense
it does and that's that's kind of where
that
conversation that i had with him her
went
um i spoke to her about how much
the costume and the makeup had terrified
her
and she laughed now i don't know if that
was a laugh out of fear or anxiety
because like i'll make self-deprecating
jokes when i'm
nervous i don't know that but
it so he was accused of
yeah here's your job as big brother okay
um i
it sounds like you're trying hard and i
you're a good model for a big brother
these days you're trying to love your
sibling the best you can i love that
and if somebody starts lobbing untrue
accusations
understand how hard this is also for
your sister and so the immediate anytime
there's some sort of discomfort
on a receiving end of a relationship
boom walls go up
and so your job as big brother is to
stay calm and
to stay collected and push back and say
nope we're not doing that
the challenge here is you showed up to
my house dressed in
goth whatever right and i i'm i
i had friends who were golf back in high
school so that's the only picture i've
got i have no idea what that means to
you
um but i want you to create a pathway
back for that relationship between your
sister and your child
and that's going to start with the
adults being the adults in the room not
forcing a six-year-old
to instantly get over the phobias or to
lob some sort of
social accusations against a
six-year-old that's nonsensical it's
insane
it's ugly it's rude right your job is to
paint a path
back and i think the hard work for you
and your wife is going to be what does a
path back
look like what is a way that we can
introduce
our child who struggles with phobias
like you say at
parks at events and things like that
what are ways we can create you know
pave a brick road towards this
relationship
but it's going to be the adults who've
got to walk that right so
i'd be i'd be gracious with your sister
i i would also
um yeah i'd put a stop to any sort of
that
nonsensical you're just nope i'm not i'm
not
this is how you showed up in my house
and it scared my my daughter
we're not gonna laugh about scaring
six-year-olds we're just not
we're not and this has nothing to do
with transgender stuff this has to do
with how you showed up at my house um
if we're gonna announce things to my
six-year-old please let me know
right because they may have all sorts of
things going on and um
but that's gonna be the hard work on
this and i know this is a difficult
journey that you're walking as a family
and i appreciate your hospitality
looking at it and so what i would tell
you the
the way i would end this call is both
and you have a right to protect your kid
especially when there's some specific
phobias that she's wrestling with
and you have a right to expect other
people to respect your kid
and continue to double down on
hospitality man you're a good big
brother and i'm grateful for you
all right um let's take a quick break
we're going to pay some bills and we'll
be right back here on the dr john dolone
show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud
and it seems that everyone has anxiety
i've been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's
not and how you can get back on the road
of being whole and well
listen you are not broken and i'm living
proof that you can get your life
back i wrote this book so everyone could
read it not just science nerds like me
and my friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndeloney.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
hey what's up this is dr john dolone
show and we are back let's go to kate in
madison wisconsin kate what's going on
hi uh thank you for taking my call hey
thank you for calling thank you for
calling it's exciting
what's up uh so just a little bit of
background i'm
27 years old and just a little over a
year ago i found out that i'm a gene
carrier for huntington's disease
uh huntington's is neurological it's
like als
dementia alzheimer's wrapped into one so
it's been a little it's been
something and just according to what
statistics i have
because this comes from my birth family
i'm adopted so i haven't actually seen
it i don't
know but statistically speaking
um one out of two right i won't make it
yes um yeah oh you're i'm talking about
you're
talking about passing along do you have
you started showing symptoms
no i haven't okay but um
because of it i've gone back to school
to become a social worker i started my
own business
uh and i've just been kind of trying to
plan for the future because i won't be
able to work for
between five and 20 years and then i'll
probably pass on
sometimes in my 60s so it's a lot
so you've gone to you've gone to
scorched earth
right that's pretty much good
good for you good for you i was thinking
when you said you are a carrier i was
thinking
that you were going to ask about having
kids and
at the last i looked and it's been a
minute the last i looked it was
a 50 chance of passing it on i think so
i thought that's what this call is going
you're talking about
you're a carrier and you're worried at
some point this switch gets flipped
and so you are planning for you just
found out that your neighbors have nukes
and so you are just
gonna start building bomb shelters just
in case right
well part of it is having kids because i
want a family but also
i don't know how to plan for my future
if i choose to have children
whether i adopt and like how do i
prepare myself as well as my family for
that
because i have no idea so number one
that sucks
i wish i had something fancy to tell you
right now i i'm trying to put myself in
your position and
just so you know i'm laughing because i
would have done the exact same thing
i would have started writing at my my
eulogy and i would have called all my
friends together
and they would have thought i was going
to be dead by the weekend and
it would have taken a while for them to
be like oh this is a maybe
and it's 30 to 40 years what and i would
have been like i know god
so i kate i'm you and so
we're in this together i wish there was
a fancy thing i could tell you that
would make it go away and it's not right
that's a scary scary
the only thing i could think that would
be scary right is to actually
feel that first tremor or that first you
know
take that first misstep and then your
heart just sings because you know right
and then you gotta go to the doctor oh
yeah when the doctor and of course if
you're like
me do you just walk through every second
of every day looking for it
um no oh you're better than me dude i
would be
oh man i mean i have moments i have some
really bad moments yeah but otherwise
i'm like okay
it's not your time you still have
between 20 and 30 years you're good
and i pray that times will catch up and
apparently finds my ketchup but i don't
know
i don't know i know but you don't have
it right
currently i do not okay i will develop
it
i want to start there okay you don't
have it
yeah so here's what i don't want you to
do
i don't i'm gonna i'm gonna oversimplify
this and i'm gonna get mean cards and
letters from the huntington's community
and it's
you're worth it okay a hundred percent
of us
don't get out of this thing alive right
yeah a hundred percent yeah um one of my
favorite psychologists
in the on planet he's a psychiatrist i
guess is irving yolum
and his he came up with the idea of
existential psychology
the reason that all of us are crazy and
we build empires in families
and religions this is his thinking is
all distilled down into one thing
because the moment we reach conscious
awareness we know that we're gonna die
and so we build all this banana stuff
like whether it's grocery stores and
roads and
we build like all kinds of things to
prop up and lean up against this one
thing and that's we're gonna we're not
gonna make it out of here
and so yeah i don't what you are
experiencing
is that 100x right because you have a
path now most of us don't know
we don't know we just go through our day
thinking it's going to be around 85.
really in our heads we think it's gonna
be about 106. all right
but it's we can look at the data you've
got a different picture in front of you
right so yeah i want to back out and i i
want to start with this premise
don't let tomorrow's future pain
steal your joy from today and
you have a different level than most of
us right so i'm not i want to minimize
what you're experiencing
at the same time every joyful second is
precious to you right
yes it is and the more you run out into
the future and pick up
cinderblocks to run back into the
present and carry with you around every
day
the more you're just gonna suck the soul
out of these precious moments that you
do have
and so there is a real
need for you to plan financially right a
real need
there is a real need for you to you're
gonna have some hard roads to go with
life insurance and with any sort of
insurance and things like that right so
instead of opening your own business you
may work for
a company that's going to have great
health insurance because you know down
the road
those are the kind of decisions that i
want you to get with a doctor
not a not the internet for god's sake
never go on the internet again kate ever
there's a phenomenal doctor here in
madison so i'm all connected with that
that is a doctor that's going to walk
with you i want you to find
a huntington's community and that may
actually have to be on the internets but
people who have walked this line
with you and are gonna humanize the
internet drama
right and there will be real people
hopefully it could be people you could
meet with in person you could go have
coffee with some folks and
meet with their family i want you to not
carry any heavier brick than you've got
to does that make sense
and yeah the internet has a vested
interest in making these bricks as heavy
as possible so you'll keep clicking
i want you to actually go make eye
contact with people even if you got to
fly somewhere
make eye contact with folks who have
experienced this who are experiencing it
family members and
really get a real picture on it does
that make sense
yeah and then you're gonna have to have
some hard conversations with your
current family with
who with your significant other right
on what family's going to look like do
you adopt do you
want to roll the dice and have kids no
one can tell you that but you
and so you're in it and it sucks
and your moments
your seconds your relationships got a
thousand times
more precious and so
do your best to get facts and data
do your best to not live way into the
future
and those are gonna happen they're like
lightning bolts they shoot into your
mind
and you go nope that's later that's a
problem for future kate
because today kate is gonna is going to
burn
all the tread off these tires right he's
going to have as many fun adventures
it's going to
do incredible meaningful work is going
to sit with folks do the things that
bring you joy
and begin to make meaning of this thing
but none of us get out of here and i
hope your story kate
is a is a magical story for everybody
because none of us know right none of us
know
life is a mist and a vapor and it goes
so fast
so so fast every second's precious
every second is precious kate thank you
for that call i know that's tough i know
that's tough i know that's tough
and we'll be thinking about you get
connected with your
doctor community people and live in the
present
thank you so much let's go to diane in
charlotte diane what's going on
hi how you guys doing we are
have the time of our life how about you
not quite so
that's why i'm so glad i was in contact
with you guys
hey i'm so glad you called so what's up
how can i help
i'm 53 years old i'm single
i grew up very poor okay
two girls out of wedlock they're grown
now okay
i was on um government assistance for
years okay i'm trying to calm down i
want to pass out on the phone
hey you are okay you're doing incredible
you're doing incredible i did not have
any guidance
um no self-confidence no self-esteem
yeah you name it
i've come upon a great job with benefits
and i'm just so overwhelmed i'm so
gracious for having this job
yeah again i never had any guidance of
how to handle money
i trusted this co-worker to tell me how
to go about
to getting more money
that was the worst mistake i made in my
life
i'm so sorry and this co-worker steal
from you or give you some kind of scheme
or something like that
yeah it was a scheme and i ran with it
yeah and
now i'm in debt okay hey diane
yeah i've done the same thing
no yes ma'am 100 of the people listening
to this show have done the same thing
whether the scheme was a leased car or
stupid credit cards
or hey give me a hundred dollars and
i'll turn it into a thousand dollars and
give me ten thousand dollars true 100
i do not know a person who hasn't made
mistakes with money
and i want you to know you're not by
yourself on this one okay
okay all right all right so keep going
so you you did something dumb now you
got
now you got debt okay now
i um let's say i have a car that i had
it was
21 years old and so working this job i
was able to
purchase a 2015 model call look at you
man hey my car's at 20.
mine's in 2006 diane you're crushing it
i'm gonna buy your car from you all
right so you gotta you got a
a new used car you're just yeah you're a
new used car i'm still paying on it
okay and i'm trying and i went into my
retirement savings to try to catch up
with the bills that i owe to try to
reduce that amount of when i'm in debt
in
and so it seems like i'm piling more and
more money
right and keep that instead of
okay hey hey i just made a mess you did
you did
okay you made a mess and you called you
called the cleanup crew
all right
you hear me yes tell me about this job
you got you said you just stumbled upon
it i don't believe that for a second i
think you're
i think you're an incredible worker and
they are lucky
it's all get out to have you they are
yeah they are see
in my younger days i knew about the job
i played softball and i knew about the
jobs they had like lance and continental
tires the people that i'll
play softball with yeah but i didn't
know how i didn't have a computer i know
how to
to get into the job but now i'm with the
post office
yeah look at that hey you guys saved our
lives during
covet i know and boy we worked out
behind off for you guys you had to get
your mailing prescriptions
i know prescription had to get my books
had to get food i got to get everything
and plus all the other stuff that we
bought just because it made us feel good
right
yeah yeah okay so
let's do this i want to back out a
second okay let's pull this apart
and we'll do it pretty quickly how much
money do you make a year
it varies okay give me a ballpark
i could make from 50 000 to 100
000 if i wanted to by doing overtime all
right
okay how much debt do you have if you
took every single penny you owe somebody
else how much is that
a hundred and thirty-two thousand
dollars
all right so here's the way we like to
uh
i work here at ramsey solutions my boss
is dave ramsey
um here's here's the language that he
uses that i love
you got a big hole right you got 130
2 000 hole and
you work like bananas for two years you
work like
a somebody that i know you can you've
been working hard your whole life
you got a big shovel too
right and you can dig out of this hole
in relatively short fashion
and along the way you're going to stand
up taller
you're going to learn a whole bunch of
new things so the next time some
knucklehead co-worker comes to you
you're going to laugh at him and go
idiot ain't getting my money here right
um or you're going to take him out to
coffee because i'm i would say idiot
you're
more compassionate and kind than me you
take him out to coffee and you're going
to say hey
you're leave you're doing this sideways
okay
okay but listen it feels like a lot
right now
and it is and you are in a great
position to crush it
and not only crush it but i know i know
i know diane at your office
you're the kind of person that people
come ask for things aren't they
yes yep you are a strong
brilliant powerful person who's been
through a lot in life and my guess is
the peace that you walk through a room
at work people gravitate towards you
yes you know and you're still positive
am i right
yes okay so this is
just another one you're not going to
beat yourself up over it
hey i'll just tell you mine was about
100 i think it was 117
000 was how big my hole was okay i had
to dig out
dave's was millions okay
so if you're sitting next to old man
dave ramsey he gonna laugh at the size
of your hole here's it
okay okay now here's what this means
you're gonna have to get on a plan
you're gonna have to get a budget you
have to be on a plan you're gonna have
to get a group of people around you
they're gonna hold you accountable and
walk alongside you
and most importantly you're gonna have
to change your entire psychology around
money
around dying around who you are okay
got it you are strong and powerful
and you just need some new information
and you're gonna be off to the races
okay okay so here's what i'm gonna do
for you number one
i'm gonna give you for free i'm gonna
give you my book
it's on it's called um redefining
anxiety
in someone in your situation this idea
of i screwed up this idea of
my past traumas this idea of money makes
me nervous
now um people coming to you with schemes
gonna make you
your heart takes off on you right your
heart starts beating fast or you get
that stomach drops
that you know that's that warm feeling
in your belly like i failed something
yeah i'm gonna give you this book and
i'm gonna give it to you for free that's
number one
number two i'm gonna send you a copy of
dave ramsey's total money makeover book
for free
okay and that's gonna walk you through
everything
hey i'm not done yet i'm gonna send you
ramsey plus
for a year it's our subscription service
here's what it is
it's got financial peace university the
gentle
step-by-step course it's nine lessons
they're digital lessons you can get
online and watch them in your house
invite your friends over they're
entertaining they're fun but they are
lessons on
why we do what we do step by step by
step
it also comes with a community whether
that's in person classes or online
classes
where you can talk through people's
journeys you can
watch all these things and it comes with
the app
the most important app i it's what i use
in my house
it tracks my money it connects to my
bank my wife and i can use it together
all of it together i want you to invite
your daughters in on this because i want
this to be a moment for you that's what
i was just telling them i won't
i don't want them to make the thing
there you go and listen
you know you know what that word is
legacy you're going to change your
family tree
and it's not too late and your grandkids
are going to live different lives
because you put a stick in the ground
at 53 years old and said no more for my
family
you know what i'm saying
listen then you're going to get all
you're going to go berserker about it
and then people at your church are going
to be like why are you suddenly six foot
six tall
why you got all these fancy new clothes
that you're paying for in cash and
you're gonna say i'm gonna run a class
at my church
on my own and then they're going it's
going to sell out and you're going to
look people in the eye
who are feeling just like you are right
now and you're going to help them stand
up tall you're going to hug them tight
you're going to say you got a big hole
but you're going to get a big shovel
we're going to work our way through this
right
but i'm such an honest person let me
tell you this okay
i went on the mr ramsey site
and i saw that he had
the trials and i've already
it told me i'm already on step two yep
which i didn't know
you know at least i have the thousands
saved there you go
see you only got seven more to go seven
more to go
and listen hey uh i'm you don't need the
trial anymore i'm gonna give it to you
for a year
okay no more trials i'm gonna give it to
you but listen
um you're gonna you are gonna have to
work hard for two years
probably probably two and a half maybe i
thought it was gonna be longer but it's
only gonna be
two years you're talking hey it's a math
problem
that means you're gonna have to be on
rice and beans ain't gonna be no more
diane going partying every night
i know you don't do that anyway i grew
up poor so they won't
yeah that's what i'm saying and you're
gonna pick up every overtime shift you
got
you're gonna embarrass those 26 year
olds when they say the words
i'm so tired you're gonna look at them
and go come on now
and then you're gonna say well cool give
me your shift because i'm gonna get paid
i'm gonna get paid i'm gonna get paid
and you're gonna have something to work
towards
work towards work towards diane i want
you to say this
out loud i'm gonna change my family tree
i'ma change my family tree starting
today
starting today and here's the thing
diane here's what happens when you make
that decision
is millions of people listening to this
right now
are gonna be driving okay millions
that's probably a little bit of
overstatement maybe 38 people listen to
his podcast
right they're driving down the road
they're mowing their yard they're
vacuuming their house they are going for
a run whatever they're doing they just
stopped
and they said diane she can change a
family tree i'm going to also
and it starts with getting in control of
your money your thoughts
your actions getting in relationships
with other people who are good for you
who aren't going to steal from you
or aren't going to sucker you into
something
and you're going to have some
generational traumas you're going to
work through diane it's going to be a
whole process but you're going to start
with
now you're on baby step two you're going
to lay out all those debts you're going
to follow a plan you're going to take a
little step in a little step in a little
step
you're gonna bring your kids with you
you're gonna bring your friends with you
you're talking about an entire new
legacy you're gonna take those bricks
out of your backpack and you're gonna
pave a new road
that your grandkids are gonna walk on
and they're gonna remember about grandma
diane
and how she said no more at 53 changed
it all
i'm so proud of you for making this call
i'm proud of you for saying no more
for being vulnerable and saying how i
finally
after 50 years i got me a great job
and then i went stepped in cha-cha again
that's cool we're gonna hose our boots
off and we're gonna keep going
i'm so proud of you diane man this
is this is why i love this show because
i hang up the phone and i'm motivated
i get motivated to continue to work
those little tiny tiny steps tiny steps
tiny steps
towards changing my family tree thank
you so much diane for this call
all right as we wrap up today's show man
i know what we're going with we're going
with
a 1991
acoustic love ballad because why not
because paul gilbert was a shredmaster
but on this particular song
paulie g picks up an acoustic guitar and
him and the rest of the
of the group unfortunately titled mr big
come on guys
y'all were all really good players y'all
could've done better than that but
1991 on the album lean into it you
dropped this classic
called to be with you and it goes like
this
hold on little girl show me what he's
done to you stand up little girl
a broken heart can't be that bad when
it's through
it's through fate will twist the both of
you
so come on baby come on over let me be
the one to show you
i'm the one who wants to be with you
deep inside i hope you feel it too
i waited on a line of greens and blues i
don't even know what that line means
i've wondered what that line means since
middle school just to be the next
to be with you i
america we're all waiting on a line of
greens and blues
maybe it's talking about salad bars or
something just to be the next to be with
you
this has been the dr john dalony show
you